I'm the new co-executive director for
the south big data innovation hub we're
based here at University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill at the Renaissance
computing institute or Renzi as many of
you may be familiar our our co-managers
of the hub or at Georgia Tech and will
list those names at the end I'm
co-presenting today with my colleague
Mike Conway who is a developer at Renzi
and helps to lead our infrastructure
working group so the federal government
and particularly the White House
recognized the need for greater
investment and a coherent strategy
around big data research and development
they initiated an initiative in 2012
investing two hundred million dollars
across six agencies in 2014 the National
Science Foundation said well we really
need to focus on regional issues in the
use of data science and development of
public/private partnerships so they've
invested about six million dollars in
2015 in founding for big data regional
innovation hubs so there's one in the
west one in the Northeast here in the
south so you're all in our region and
one in the Midwest and as part of that
they are also providing 10 million
dollars in funding across all four hubs
to do to fund some partnerships to fund
some applied research where we're
applying data science to real world
problems so the National Science
Foundation I don't know how many of you
are familiar typically funds kind of
basic research so they fund basic
research in critical technologies and in
data science they fund some
infrastructure development through the
dibs program they fund education in
computer science and data science but
the hub's is something new for them
there you know this is really kind of
breaking new ground is funding
partnerships connecting academic
researchers with industry with
nonprofits with government to apply data
science to comply computer science tools
to help solve real world problems
so as I said they're four regions for
hubs Rene best dawn is the executive
director at Columbia for the Northeast
hub Melissa Cragen is the executive
director in the Midwest hub that's based
at University of Illinois
urbana-champaign where the
supercomputing Institute is Meredith Lee
who's been also very active in the maker
movement is the executive director in
the west hub based at Berkeley and then
myself and Renata Rawlings gas are here
in the south and we go everywhere from
Texas to Delaware that may not be quite
what you think of as the south but they
were following census borders there so
what are the goals of the hub well first
and foremost to stimulate agile and
sustainable national big belt of big
data innovation ecosystem both at the
regional level and at the national level
accelerate partnerships between people
across sectors business academia
government nonprofits who apply data
science and analytics to advance science
to address societal challenges and spur
economic development in the region so
right now we're still in start-up mode
so what I'm telling you now may change a
little bit as we're moving around the
region and finding out what people want
to need but the primary goal as i said
is funding or funding helping to build
accelerate public-private partnerships
grow communities of practice around
different verticals which I'll describe
in a moment connecting data scientists
with domain scientists industry and
practitioners to develop sets of best
practices share lessons learned and
success stories not unlike what you're
doing here at PI data facilitating data
sharing and shared cyber infrastructure
collaborations resources and services
and Mike will talk about this
momentarily and building data science
capacity through facilitating data
science education and workforce
development so we had an all-hands
meeting in December bringing together
two hundred and about 50 participants
who formed into 68 teams and they
submitted proposals to the NSF and the
NSF will about be about to announce the
winners of those proposals
to launch new projects in the coming
year and there will be another call for
proposals for funding coming up this
fall we're still in startup so we're
setting up an advisory board as i said
the spoke proposals the first round will
go out soon we're standing up some
working groups of which i hope some of
you might might want to help participate
we've developed a Memorandum of
Understanding between all four hubs so I
frequently get asked how much
coordination is there between the hubs
we talk weekly we go week to each
other's meetings we're having retreats
so there is quite a bit of coordination
going across the country in the hubs
we're beginning to stand up some of
these communities of practice around
different verticals doing some outreach
to begin to hear from you what do you
need how can we be help of help to what
you want to accomplish the rd
communities this is just an initial set
I think as we hear from the communities
what they want these may change a bit
but infrastructure is number one data
sharing healthcare analytics mobile
health metro data science or what they
call smart and connected cities privacy
and security industrial big data and
energy it materials in advanced
manufacturing and natural resources and
coastal hazards so we're beginning to
set up a series of community calls for
people to share expertise and what
projects they're working on in these
problem spaces we're also serving as a
connector and convener hosting series of
workshops some of which are focused on
these verticals are focused on some of
these problem spaces we can also do some
of matchmaking if you come to me and say
I need expertise in these things I can
reach into my networks or reach across
networks on the hubs to find people who
might be able to help you we've says it
is standing up three working groups
community engagement right now we're
working on developing some use cases for
big data tools to determine the
applicant applicability for these
different verticals partnering with the
high performance computing folks
particularly exceed the education and
workforce working group we've stood up
to programs funded by the cim
puter community consortium our computing
community consortium the computing
research association so they funded two
programs one day to start and I see some
data start folks in here when I shout
out yay we had startup companies they
needed expertise in data science so we
partnered them with students who wanted
summer internships to take the
theoretical skills they were learning in
the classroom and apply it to real world
problems and so we had a class of six
this year to start but we hope to expand
this as we go and sep tember 27th those
graduate students will be presenting
their work to an audience of startup
folks and government folks and I think
at least one of them may be more have
been hired on by those companies and
Georgia Tech has a program called peppy
where they're partnering faculty with
industry and the cyber infrastructure
group the most interesting important
group i think i will be mapping existing
collaboration services and resources
identifying hub member needs the still
trying to facilitate distributed data
sharing computing and analysis across
institutions and partners focus on open
source focus on federated and of note
it's been announced but we're still
working out the details is Microsoft
Azure we've got three million dollars in
credits across the hubs that will start
being awarding to two projects in the
pin the fall other companies are also
coming to us also wanting to provide
this so look for announcements there and
with that i'm going to hand it over to
Mike Conway well hey everybody I was a
last minute addition hence my artisanal
a badge here I'm with renze um and I'm a
software developer so I'm really nervous
standing up you're talking to you guys
because I man I'm just a sort of a quiet
nerd but
but I'm really proud to work on some of
the projects I've been involved with and
particularly proud to have worked for
dr. Regan more who just retired who in
his face is actually a really important
leader in the field of data science and
data management so I'm going to try to
transmit some of what he talks about and
some of what we're doing and how it may
play into all the wonderful things I see
represented here at PI data so we're
going to talk about you know we're
talking about applying Python and are
and tools like that to data mining and
you know managing scientific data is
primarily where I've interacted with
Python but we want to start talking
about now how do you what is the context
in which your Python tools your our
tools are applied to data at some scale
in collaborations and then how is that
data managed so you have the data and
the computation and what we're really
interested in is that sweet spot or
those two were those two things meet and
it's a context I think in which we can
do sharing and partnerships in a way
that is sustainable in and sort of
technically achievable and that's what
I'm here to talk about today so I'm with
something called the data net Federation
consortium which was one of the major
NSF data net grants that leah was
mentioning where we're building national
scale infrastructure for scientific
collaboration so this ranges all the way
from the high end with things like Babar
and the Large Hadron Collider kak and
large of astronomy datasets so big data
it also includes things like sensor data
so we work with things like the ocean
observatories Institute gathering sensor
data being able to manage that data
share it with others aggregate the same
with things like NASA modis NOAA climate
data so there's the big data side and
then there's the small data side which
our researchers working working on small
projects where they want to collaborate
together we use each other's data so
that's the sort of area where we want to
play so it's about the preservation and
publication of data and repeatable
science this is one of the goals we have
with
yeah this is one of the goals we have
with DFC and I think this plays into
what the data hub is doing we also want
to look at groups that control their
data and then they federated data
collections with other organizations so
NASA NOAA and Wren seem a collaborate on
a project they each control their data
but they can share it as one federated
collection and again this confluence of
data and computation is the real sweet
spot and I'm getting the speed it up so
I'm going to kind of pass through some
of these slides so um so we have here
represented we have the industry and
research in academia and the data hub
environment to me is this mixing area
where we're speaking the language of
open source so everything we do is open
source software and we're building both
the software and the discipline in order
to take these pieces and create
repeatable shareable science okay um so
the big data hub environment it's about
data management and sharing okay we're
doing computation but where does that
data go and how can other people find
and discover it and how can they use it
10 years from now so part of that is
about being able to take your scientific
data and derive metadata about it based
on your computation the processes the
analyses that create data sets and be
able to keep that preserve that and then
allow that to be discovered in many
different ways it's about long-term
preservation so our background actually
started with the US National Archives so
the software i work on was a narrow
project for about 10 years so how not
only can we do this computation but how
can we keep this data and make a
meaningful 10 years from now so working
at this intersection of big data
management and computation the kinds of
excellent work that I've seen
represented here at PI data and that's I
think where the big data hub is a place
for software developers to work together
to innovate to solve some of these
problems providing them a place for
science to happen okay so basically
where we're coming from is this idea I
want to want to introduce it's actually
a pretty simple idea but it's unique and
I think it's spreading is this idea of
policy based data management um so the
idea here is that each data object
a product of analysis or so forth is it
is treated as a resource this bridge is
everything from high-performance file
systems to no sequel databases you know
just think of everything as a URL which
were already sort of doing so all
actions on any resource that is kept in
these federated data stores triggers
policies at the core of the system and
those policies can range from simple
replication and check summing and fixity
checking all the way to managing things
like FERPA or HIPAA you know think about
the kinds of policies that control your
data it could also be things like
embargoes so then the kinds of policies
we apply our security and audit
preservation rules data transformation
metadata extraction etc okay the idea
this is again is what basically where
regan more comes from and what DFC is
built on is this idea that as you apply
policies to these data you keep in your
data grids you can keep metadata about
the application of those policies the
idea then is that you can then assess
how your policies are working so that
you can do things like show data use to
NSF so that you can show you're
complying with license agreements so
that you you're complying with again
federal guidelines things like HIPAA
okay the idea then is you can extend
that into federated environments other
hubs where each location enforces its
own policies and controls its own
policies so this is sort of like
building an Internet of data if you will
a sort of below what we think of as the
internet and that and that Internet of
data is is freely networked and then ok
so I'm wearing my I rods hat here
because I also work with the our rods
consortium so the I rods data grid is
open-source software that we're using at
the hub it's a generic data management
infrastructure for supporting data
preservation publication sharing and
data analysis and it's all based around
this idea of policy management of your
data okay
uh give me a hug okay so what I wanted
to talk about is if we think about our
data what we're doing in terms of
applying Python or are to computation I
want to present this idea of the life
cycle of your scientific data and what
the NSF at large scale is trying to do
and how maybe it fits into what the big
data hubs and innovation centers can
offer so it's the idea that you start
with a project collection maybe you're
doing small science doing a survey of a
particular piece of land you know doing
bird counts or things like that so you
have private data that's controlled by
your local policies these may be shared
on a datagrid perhaps with groups and so
you have distribution policies to
control for example embargo data among
researchers and this is where things
like PI data come in now you introduce
the idea of data processing pipelines
your data is being analyzed um and
you're creating products data products
and so you have service policies that
are managing this so I run an analyses
on a piece of data I keep the inputs I
keep the parameters and I can even keep
the peace of computational code that was
used to create products and that's all
kept together and I can repeat it okay
we're seeing a lot of this um and then
the idea is that those pipelines go into
digital libraries perhaps associated
with a publication so for example in the
art world we work the Odom Institute on
social science research and the
dataverse network one of the things that
they're doing as part of their business
now is that researchers who are
publishing papers have to submit both
their computation and their data to the
Odom Institute and they have to be able
to run your computation and verify your
results before you publish so this is
the kind of thing that these data
processing pipelines and digital
libraries play into this forms reference
collections things like NASA modis data
for example that are being preserved and
you have policies for representing that
data for discovery and so forth and
federated into be sustained collections
and I think this is the target endpoint
to me of these these big data hubs okay
so this is just an example at EU debt
the really big users of this kind of
approach and this is the be too safe
infrastructure which is used for as a
reply k repository of scientific
research data and this is just showing
different ask different nodes on the EU
debt network and how they can manage
their policy their data through their
policies and yet federated to create one
topological topological connection
that's an eye chart okay the other thing
I really wanted to talk about briefly is
this marriage of computation and data
and this is what we're working on right
now there's lots of ways to compute
whether you're doing something at a
national laboratory or you're sending
stuff to attack using exceed resources
or you have a piece of computation that
you can put in a docker container these
are the kinds of things we're working
out but the idea is first moving data to
compute so the big data hubs is a place
to do this sort of thing okay so you can
for example we work with cyber's who
used to be the I plant collaborative
doing grand challenge biology out in the
West okay and so they have their
researchers bring their own computation
provided as a docker container they put
it into an environment a visual
environment where then they can run that
data and manage all the products the
input parameters and everything back it
up track provenance okay this is good
for small data sets you know hundred
gigabytes or so what we're working on
now are also infrastructure for moving
compute to the data so if you've got
petabytes of data and you want you want
to take your Python code for example
package it up and be able to find where
that data is at rest ship that data out
have the computation done on the data at
rest again tracking provenance and being
repeatable these are the kind of things
that are happening at the BD hub young
okay so I'll let you finish up so stay
here stay here quick questions umm so so
alone yes we have a growing team and we
definitely want to hear from you what
are you interested in how can we help
we're looking for your guidance so with
that thank you
close new questions a couple questions
so just out of curiosity what are your
policies or guarantees for export
controlled data is this like jeopardy do
I have like not heard the music playing
I got nervous um so my Dodge is I'm a
software developer so what we are doing
what we have what we are doing or what I
was describing is a system or a approach
a discipline in which we provide the
framework for you to express your
policies so in a sense um but for
example you know the way the web works
because urls verbs behave a certain way
we're providing sort of a similar system
where you run this apache server and you
can encode your export policies for
example and that's where I will leave it
we're providing the framework for you to
encode those policies and then you can
audit them and make sure they're being
enforced okay question back here don't
give him the microphone too late yeah
but um so it makes me wonder let's say
somebody has a set of export policies
right how are they gonna is there a
mechanism in either enforce or envision
that would allow them to package up
those policies and share them with other
people who might need very much the same
thing yes so there think of them as
little modules you can plug in one of
the main things is that that your
collaboration is controlled through the
Federation's that you control
administrative Lee so it's not just
checking the IP and making sure that
this is not an IP that's on the State
Department list it's about you decide
what grids you feder a twit who on that
grid is able to access your data and
once done it appears as one uniform
collection whether you're going through
the web or some other way yeah okay
great thank you so much this is amazing
this is the kind of stuff that gives me
a goose bumps